Don Lemon is completely insane he is
awoke leftist who has been completely
broke and once you are completely broke
through woke you make everything about
race here he is talking to New York City
mayor Eric Adams about the death of
Tyree Nichols now Tyree Nichols is the
black man
who by every estimation was just
unjustly killed by five black police
officers they were all black there were
no whities involved in this thing no
honkies okay but of course when five
black officers kill a black man it has
to be of course racism here's Don Lemon
okay well let me ask you the chief CJ
Davis one in my interview with her she
said that all the officers being black
it takes race off the table do you agree
with that
uh no no I don't uh I think that I
understand what uh the chief was saying
and I think she really handled this
situation in a very professional Way She
Moves swiftly she's sure that those
officers were removed from the
Department she took all the necessary
steps uh but I think a race is still on
the table of when a culture of policing
historically has treated those from
different groups differently uh even
when the individuals are from that same
group that culture can still exist and
we have to zero in on it being honest
about it and making sure that we
properly train police for the realities
of the cities that they are policing do
you realize how crazy this is uh there
you have Eric Adams who happens to be
black and Don Lemon who happens to be
black I don't care that either one of
them are black I really don't
um and I generally don't care about the
color of police officers or and I don't
care about the color of the perpetrators
if you break the law if you're
threatening people all those things it
has to be dealt with now this is this by
again every estimation is a completely
unjust killing what they did was
horrible but if you think that five
black police officers were acting with
racism in their heart as they as they
killed this black guy then then racism
has no meaning whatsoever
black people are the biggest anti-black
racist like what are we actually saying
here but this was the danger of the woke
and this is why you must get woke out of
schools because once it has permeated
all of the institutions once you have
taught a generation of young people to
think everything is about gender and
race and those immutable characteristics
you can get them to believe any crazy
that you want
foreign
[Music]